yeah how far would you travel now for
vag nice uh
car or plane
car
and let me let me describe it for you
are you single now yes okay so here we
go all right oh I thought you're going
to describe the car it's a good car it's
solid it's a low rider it was built in
the last three years uh Hydraulics no um
so um girl okay the most beautiful girl
you've ever seen your life so funny has
her own career right she's a liar a liar
or a lawyer a liar
she lied no she's a lawyer okay she's a
lawyer right and you just you've never
met anyone like that before right but
she's just like I don't have a car so
you have to come to me oh also okay so
you can only see you between the hours
of 3 P.M and 7 P.M Peak trap LA traffic
no you can't throw that out there no
that's that's real all right that's real
because just just because you say oh I
only lived 20 miles away that's that's
cool but when you account for LA traffic
20 miles can equal God an hour and a
half yeah you're right you're right
you're right that is real so how long
how long uh well let's see first of all
the lawyer thing was like forget lawyer
then forget forget she owns a um Pokemon
shop oh that's cute oh that turns him
off so am I going for a Chase card or
something am I going am I going for a
yeah no she has they have these she
sells these like limited editions
gold-plated Pokemon cards that's right
and she like buys them online she's like
one of the biggest dealers in the world
is that not better than lawyer or no I'm
okay I guess it's better yeah okay okay
so a taco shop nice is that better
honestly I wouldn't uh unless the career
was something where I'd Quest like are
we saying that she doesn't have a car
oh no she
um
because there's a lot of variables
it's so specific all right well because
okay you say half what's the furthest I
would drive so okay but it's unreliable
it's unreliable
she has a car but it's unreliable yeah
okay I would I would go with
90 minutes no that's long 90 90 minutes
that's a movie so an hour and a half
you'll wait that's it there and back now
is this every day or is this like uh one
twice a week I know
okay if it's once a week 90 minutes okay
or twice a week 90 minutes yeah yeah uh
one yeah I'm sorry if it was twice a
week an hour uh once a week 90 minutes
oh wow wow wow wow yeah okay now flight
how far would you fly
Texas
yeah that's good that's good yeah yeah
yeah yeah Delaware [__] two and a
half yeah yeah yeah no Delaware no
Delaware right no Delaware what would I
do I would FL I would draw well I drove
to Long Beach every day every day yeah
and that what's that along it could get
to up to an hour and a half depending on
when you were coming it was big traffic
oh my God yeah you're in love it so
sweet yeah yeah I know
you guys are done back to me
okay so so the uh the girl that I was
seeing I was driving from Long Beach to
Valencia yeah pretty much every day and
then when she was going to college she
was going to college in San Diego so I
still had a two-hour Drive either way
wow and I was doing I was doing that
what level were you at career-wise
career-wise I want to say I was um
probably year five year five year five
uh at the time I had already done uh all
that on Nickelodeon I was already a
touring comedian and at the time I was
working on a pilot uh here in Burbank
with Jamie Foxx it was a pilot it was
going to be like the new version of In
Living Color and you sketch comedy show
yeah so I was driving from San Diego to
Warner Brothers to be there by 10 a.m
every day so and I was driving to San
Diego every day for a committee oh I was
committed so I was falling asleep on the
drive to to Burbank yeah from San Diego
wow and uh I was falling asleep at the
you know when we were doing the table
reads it was bad
you were like yeah addicted oh yeah I
was I was 25 and I was all hormones yeah
I was all horny is she still in your
life or no no no no she moved on she
married got kids and everything like
that right right right how long did that
last you know what we were together for
almost four years whoa yeah and then
when I didn't move her into the house
because when I bought a house I was like
hey I got a house no longer got an
apartment and she's like like yeah we
got a house I'm like no we don't
I gotta help I see I see she got mad
that I didn't propose him oh the whole
thing were you thinking about it or no
no I'm still not thinking about it so
but also you were just say you're young
yeah but yeah you know she was she
couldn't came from an old family was
very much like you know are we doing
this because the family thought that she
was wasting time and she was having fun
I can't say she was wasting time she was
having fun but yeah she never moved in I
never moved her in whoa did you ever get
married no no but uh after I broke up
with uh that particular girlfriend
um I wound up I wound up moving in a
different girlfriend less than a year
later
I'm sorry with her son and uh that uh
you know he became my stepson and now to
this day we're still in each other's
lives oh I'm no longer with her but we
still we're still friends like us I get
it yeah I don't fight with Mike's about
shirts uh I doubt I would fit in her
shirt I could try look like a pack of
chorizo
yeah yeah but we're cool and and the
kid's still in your life yeah absolutely
yeah cool yeah you look at them like a
son absolutely oh cool the sun yeah yeah
and how long was that like God I you
know I got him when he was seven whoa
and he's about to turn 26 this year
whoa and how long did that relationship
last uh almost oh god well there's I'm
gonna say safe 13 years all right
do you have a fear like I do or what of
commitment or not just commitment it's
not commitment it's not commitment don't
look at me I'm not looking at you I'm
looking at the wall oh okay I look at my
own head what is what is your fear my
fear is this okay I won't look no you
have to look you listen it's fine it's
fine it's just that
because you don't have any biological
children no I don't me neither